one of the biggest charity events in las
vegas is back
this week in style the clark county
medical society alliance's
20th annual spring fashion show coming
up
rocky theas is live with the wind to
tell us all about it hey rocky hey you
guys yes i'm so excited to spread the
word about this we're going to start
with sherry here
of the organization and we are working
it for women's alzheimer's right
we are indeed yes we've learned that
more women suffer from alzheimer's than
men
actually two-thirds of the population of
the people diagnosed are women
and of course women tend to be
caregivers as well so that's really our
focus this year is to try to help this
population
and improve their lives and yeah
alzheimer's is it's not just about the
patient it's about the family as well so
i love that it's about both
let's talk about your organization and
what you guys do for the community in
general
okay great thank you yes so we are a
full volunteer
group and our goal is to raise money
through health initiatives and keep it
right here in clark county nevada
and our goal this year with women's
alzheimer's is to raise a hundred
thousand dollars wow
with big goals so yeah our fingers are
causing
their costs so excited now we did
mention
the fashion show so let's talk fashion
with shirley here of the organization as
well
what are you guys doing for the fashion
show how can people enjoy
okay first of all we'll have a fashion
show featuring the models with our
baumann uh moment of paris we have a
silent auction too as you can see this
lovely purse
you can have them handbags jewelries
activewear and whatnot you know just
check out our site
at ccmsalv.org and you can also
donate and push the donate button over
there
that is amazing now the fashion show is
sold out completely so that is very
exciting especially
within a pandemic obviously we are
social distancing so the
limited capacity helped you guys sell
out the event a little bit right
well we never have a problem selling out
the event actually you know but
this year it sold out in a heartbeat
because everybody was so quick to not
only get back to
well life is normal like that they know
and then just be together and support
this wonderful organization and clause
absolutely it helps right now
everybody's
you know needs a little love and support
and helping give back to others is
really helpful so
lastly here but not least how can people
get to the um get to the actual
silent auction to bid again we
just visit our website ccmsalv.org
and we have our facebook page as well
clark county medical society alliance
and click the
donate button and you know you can all
donate for a worthy worthy cause which
is women's alzheimer's
absolutely thank you so much coming up
later in the show we're going to talk
about what else is on that silent
auction list it's not just fashion guys
it's very exciting